what's going on guys
last night was the 88th annual Academy
Awards and you know what it was actually
a pretty good show
Chris Rock navigated some treacherous
waters there were some surprise winners
some actual funny moments but that still
doesn't make them immune to the
grouchy's it's our fourth annual
grouchy's where we say dumb stuff about
the most glamorous night in showbiz
before we get started I'd like to thank
our sponsors at Best Buy bring home a
win from the Windows Store only at Best
Buy
our first award what's a biggie right
off the bat the BuzzFeed gift for the
night you may say jiff but I'll say gift
til I die the nominees are Lady gaga
flipping the f out during her
performance Mark Ruffalo Lincoln like a
boss Danish girl director Tom Hooper
being a particularly British dandy oh
hello and the crowd she goes to Michael
Keaton's fist pump the guy's a champ and
by the way if you want to win a Best
Picture Oscar put Keaton in there that's
two years in a row he's two for two Leo
may be king of the world but Michael
Keaton king of Hollywood the next
grouchy is for thee I would totally
watch that award and it goes to Tracy
Morgan's the Danish girl on a Danish
girl
how awesome is it to see Tracy Morgan
all the way back from his terrible
accident Tracy that might have been the
funniest moment of the night next up is
the John Travolta mispronunciation award
which fun fact was named for the
mumbling bumbling buffoon John Travolta
name is our APIs attend does e and the
winner comments mispronunciation of Best
Original Song winning movie Spectre
writing zone huh I've heard that
somewhere before spectra this next
category has a curse word in it it's the
I'm King hungry award and the winner is
all of these stars waving money around
trying to buy Girl Scout cookies you
know stars being hungry at the Oscars
this is a running theme Ellen with the
pizzas now it's Chris Rock selling
cookies look at Morgan Freeman one of
the greatest actors of our time reduced
to begging for cookies by the way Chris
Rock yeah The Thin Mint box but you were
not waving around Thin Mints my friend
these are delicious minty chocolatey
Thin Mints hmm then Mitch our next
grouchy is the Stallone reaction of the
night award which goes to the best
reaction to Sylvester Stallone not
winning an Oscar the nominees are Arnold
Schwarzenegger slides just remember I
made it what they say to me you are the
best Michael Rapaport photo is this what
Duff is going on and the winner
our very own engineer jte who really
flipped the F out over this use the
worst of all of them she is not happy I
just want to say America's not dead just
Sylvester Sloan's chances of ever
winning an Oscar
don't play me off yet because there are
more grouchy's to give out this next one
is the was that necessary award the
nominees are stacey dash for pretty much
confusing the audience minions because
we haven't maxed out on minions yet this
guy in a bear suit that leo was not
amused by and the winner Matt Damon CGI
beard how many man-hours went into
rendering every fake strand of Matt
Damon's computer beard here's a little
insider secret if you don't shave you
can grow a beard next up let's objectify
some folks with the hottest person award
the nominees are Sofia Vergara
Olivia Wilde and the winner
henry cavill i can say if that's a
handsome guy and that british accent
that tux
i think we found our new James Bond
calves oh Henry Cavill here's another
grouchy coming at you it's the that
didn't help award and it goes to the
scrolling thank yous you tried to keep
the speeches short and not full of names
but I'll tell you the speeches were
totally full of names and so long that
they all had to be played off by
apocalypse now music even though I would
never have believed this in films at the
moment it's a wonderful time to be an
actor and I'm firing steed bowling all
the people in Fox and Yuri you see I
just won't say one quite serious thing
and I've been thinking about this a lot
actually why'd you mix a little John
Williams in there huh by the way I just
stick Williams and morricone up on the
balcony haven't they paid their dues
this next grouchy is the weird neckwear
award and let me tell you the boys are
bringing it the nominees are Ryan
Gosling for his white bowtie Louis
Gossett jr. for his medallion this
Captain Jack Sparrow Velveteen Rabbit
jacket Mad Max dude wearing a skull and
crossbones necklace and the winner Jared
Leto who wore a carnation
as a tie is that a joker thing now it's
time for thee I thought I had it in the
bag award the nominees are the revenant
for Best Picture Sylvester Stallone for
Best Supporting Actor and the winner
Mark Ruffalo for Best Supporting Actor
who for a split second thought he had it
and the Oscar goes to
Margaret okay pause right here in this
split-second in this moment in time it
could go in either direction mark
ruffalo is like is it me
and then violence seriously though mark
Rylance
it's my pleasure to present the final
award of the evening it's the in
memoriam award which goes to the meme
that we're no longer going to see and
the winner all of the Leo doesn't have
an Oscar memes they're meaningless Leo
finally won is Oscar or did well that's
it for the fourth annual grouchy's so
what'd you think of the Academy Awards
what was your favorite moment what was
your least favorite moment let us know
in the comments section below we want to
know what you thought I want to thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter now it's time for me to go
get some sleep bye bye thanks again to
Best Buy for sponsoring this episode for
more info click the link in the
description below